- Hi everyone.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the Homeroom Livestream.
It's been a while since we did one,
but we're back and we
have an amazing guest,
Wendy Kopp, CEO of Teach for All,
also the founder of Teach for America.
We're gonna talk about her journey
and all of her learnings about education
and where we might be going.
But before we do that,
I will give my standard announcements.
First, a reminder that
we are a not-for-profit
here at Khan Academy.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about gonna
khanacademy.org/donate
and making a donation of any size.
It really does make a difference
and it's what allows us to serve millions,
tens of millions of
students around the world.
The next thing I'd like to
make sure that we recognize
many folks who have stepped up,
especially when the pandemic hit
and more folks than ever were
dependent upon Khan Academy.
Special thanks to Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
Novartis, Fastly, and General
Motors for really stepping up.
And as we all know, unfortunately,
we're still in this pseudo-pandemic mode,
but even post-pandemic
this is where Khan Academy
might be even more important to make sure
that we can get everyone back up to speed
and have a strong foundation,
and having everyone
learn at their own pace.
Last but not least,
there is a version of this
livestream in podcast form,
wherever you get your podcasts,
Homeroom with Sal, the podcast.
With that out of the way,
I'm so excited to introduce Wendy Kopp,
who I consider a good friend
and someone who I generally look up to
in all things in my life,
including founding
organizations and all the rest.
Wendy, welcome.
- Thank you.
So good to be here.
Looking forward.
- So, maybe a good, and
I'll remind everyone
who's watching on Facebook or YouTube,
any questions you have for
Wendy about her journey
or about education generally,
put 'em in the message boards.
We'll be able to look at those questions
and I'll try to surface as many as I can
during our conversation.
But Wendy, maybe a good place to start.
I think a lot of, maybe
a lot of folks have heard
for Teach for All, maybe not everyone has.
A lot of folks might have
heard for Teach for America,
some might not have.
What is Teach for All and
what is Teach for America?
- So, I'll start with Teach for All.
Teach for All started
just about 14 years ago.
And it was, I mean, I had my head down,
and I'll get back to this in a minute,
just working to grow the
impact of Teach for America,
which I had started
maybe 30 plus years ago.
And I wasn't thinking at all
about the rest of the world,
but there was just something in the water.
And I started meeting amazing people,
social entrepreneurs
from all over the world,
who were interested in seeing
something similar happen
in their countries.
And so, they were looking
for support and help
and that led to the
launch of Teach for All
as a network of independent,
locally led organizations
now in 60 countries around the world
that all share a common purpose,
which is to develop collective leadership
to ensure all kids
fulfill their potential.
And we all share a common
approach for doing that,
which is really kind of the approach that
we pioneered initially
at Teach for America
of enlisting promising leaders,
people of all different
academic backgrounds
and career interests, and
committing at least two years
to teach in under-resourced communities,
investing in their leadership,
supporting them as they
commit really their lives
to working as leaders and advocates
for the systemic changes
necessary to create
a fair and equitable and
excellent education system.
- There's so much in
there I hope to unpack.
You just explained a little bit about
how Teach for All came to
be and its theory of action.
And it really did, to some degree,
emerge out of the work
that you've been doing
for many decades at Teach for America.
Tell us a little bit about that journey
because you were quite
young when you started
and I know there's a lot
of young people listening
who for the most part,
everyone wants to find
purpose in their life,
everyone wants to know how
do I provide for my family,
but even more important potentially
make a dent in the
universe make a difference.
How did you find your purpose
through Teach for America
and then Teach for all?
- It's so interesting, Sal
because this started when
I was a college senior
and I was in a funk for the
first time in my life, really.
I mean, I had been completely driven,
taking on one issue or another,
and then I got to my senior year
and I realized I have to
figure out what I'm gonna do
for the rest of my life.
And our generation was
called the Me Generation.
Supposedly we all just wanted to go out
and work for banks and
management consulting firms.
And I just, I didn't want to do that.
And I just found myself
just searching for a way
to assume a big responsibility
and make a real difference in the world
and I got this sense that I wasn't alone,
that there were thousands
of other people out there
searching for exactly the same thing.
And as I went through all of that,
I'd also become just a very
concerned college student
focused on the inequities in our country
and particularly on the
issues in education.
The fact that where kids are born
does so much to predict
educational outcomes
and life outcomes and one day
all that just came together.
And I thought, why
aren't we being recruited
as aggressively to commit
just two years to teach
in urban and rural public
schools in our country,
as we were being recruited
to commit just two years
to work on Wall Street?
And I just became completely
obsessed with this idea.
I thought it was gonna change the country.
It was gonna channel all this
energy in the classrooms,
which was gonna be really important
for kids growing up today,
but I also thought how
different would the country be
if we took all these
quote, promising leaders,
and have their first
two years out of college
be teaching in low-income communities
instead of working at banks.
I thought that would
change our priorities,
our consciousness as a country.
So that was the big idea.
I needed a thesis topic.
It was an idea that was
very quickly far beyond me.
Yeah, that's the
beginning of it, at least.
- Well, I think to some
degree it has changed America.
I think many of those people
might have gone into banking or something.
Not that there's anything
wrong with that too.
There's many people who
do very powerful things
and very important things after that.
But I do think, the
number of people I know
who are Teach for America alumni,
who know something about education,
who care about the issue,
and some of them that stayed in education,
some of them have gone
into other professions,
but I think it has changed them
and it has changed how they lead.
It has changed how they,
how their organizations that they now lead
think about education.
But I want to go back to
that moment because I, too,
as a senior and I think
senior year, I was probably,
we were probably similar in certain ways.
I felt like I had all this energy.
I felt like I had all of
the stuff for the world,
but I was like,
where do I get the maximum
impact on the world?
And I did also sometimes have big dreams,
but then I was like, well,
how do I make that happen?
So what did you do that
allowed you to take
that pretty bold vision
and turn it into actual action
that eventually did get pretty close
or even better than that bold vision?
'Cause eventually you went global.
That wasn't even part
of your original vision.
- Yeah.
So I think I had a gift in that
I had a thesis requirement.
I mean, I had to write
an undergraduate thesis
and I was also really
searching for a topic
and I decided this would be the topic.
And that really forced me
to think a lot about this.
I mean, I researched the policy context,
the previous models that
we could learn from,
like the Peace Corps
or there was a Federal Teacher
Corps actually in the 60s,
or Vista in the US.
I looked at the mood on college campuses.
And honestly, I spent a
lot of the thesis research
looking for this.
I was just, the more I got into it,
the more it just was so
clear the timing was perfect
and this must be happening.
I was looking, who's doing this?
Because at the time, first of all,
there were huge teacher shortages.
I mean, huge headlines,
like 1,200 teachers short in New York,
1,000 teachers short in LA.
There was also a real interest
in the country for the first.
Fortune magazine cover stories on how
corporate America was
gonna take on education.
And I just thought...
Yeah anyway, that became
how I did it, honestly.
Like I ended up becoming,
I realized no one's doing it
and the time is gonna pass.
Like, someone has to do it.
And so I developed a four page plan
saying this is how we're gonna do it.
And turned in the thesis,
boil it down into 30 pages,
and I sent it to all those executives
quoted in that magazine article.
There was no email.
I was mailing letters,
calling, following up,
and I got a few meetings
off of that, those letters.
And again, it was one of those ideas
that was capturing people.
And I got a seed grant.
I spent my summer just
trying to meet anyone
who would meet me.
Of course, I had no credibility.
I mean, I would send 100 letters
and get a meeting or two.
But as I tell everyone,
you can get 98 no's or 99,
if you get one person saying yes,
and that sort of became
how like ultimately,
we gained a little traction.
But honestly, one more thing to share.
Everywhere I went, I mean,
I was getting into superintendents
and potential donors, and various people.
Again, I would meet one person
and they would lead me to others.
Everywhere I went, people
said this is a great idea.
It will never work.
And the reason they
thought it wouldn't work
is they thought the college
students would never do it.
I had a list of 100
campuses, public and private,
historically black colleges
and Ivy League schools.
And people looked at the list and said
you'll never get kids from these schools
to want to teach in
low-income communities.
And that was the one thing I had a reason
to have conviction about.
And so that became the plan.
We're gonna show people.
So, people were walking through the door,
other recent grads.
I mean, we'd launched a
grassroots recruitment campaign,
flyers under doors, again, no email.
And, you know, we had 2,500 people apply
within three or four
months that generated media
after I, yeah, I mean, one
year after I graduated,
it had all come together.
We had 500 people in
an auditorium embarking
on a summer training Institute.
We had had experienced teachers
from all over the country
and urban and rural areas come together
to be trainers for them.
We had school systems in six
places agree to hire them.
And somehow we raised two
and a half million dollars
to fund it.
Anyway, that was the first year.
But I always tell people
that's when the learning curve
began because these folks started teaching
and we realized how hard this would be.
And that's what's kept me in it.
You know,
just the incredible learning
curve and learning journey
about how to actually do this well,
like how to recruit and select
people who are ready for this
and train and support them
to succeed with their kids,
to learn the right lessons,
to ultimately fulfill
their potential as a force
for the systemic changes that we need.
Yeah.
- I want to get into that in a second,
but I also want to make sure
we don't glaze over some things
that I think you just glazed over.
You have this thesis and that
does seem like a powerful,
forcing function to doing your research,
thinking through the plan,
et cetera, et cetera.
But then I am really fascinated
by that moment from idea
to actually starting to get
a little bit of traction.
So you were literally took
copies of essentially your thesis
or version of your thesis.
You put 'em in like manila
envelopes, figure it out.
Somehow the mailing address,
like you just say, like,
you know, big corporation X,
which you could find the address
and you just put the name
of the CEO on top and hoping,
and it did actually work.
- Okay, so I had a mix of people.
I took the names in the article quoted
about how we needed like
the head of the business
round table at the time
or the next person.
And yeah, I looked up their addresses
and mailed them letters and
then I would call and follow up.
And I also added some other CEOs
from random companies out of like
the book of big corporation.
I mean, it, honestly, I had
the advantage of naivete
and I had been, I mean,
so I got seven meetings
off those letters.
That's one thing to note, I sent 30.
- That's pretty good.
- I got seven meetings,
not necessarily with the CEOs, by the way,
but whoever they handed them down to,
and one of those meetings, someone said,
you can use our office in Manhattan.
So I got some office
space and the other said,
it was just taken with the
idea and it's a long story,
but he said,
if you can get Princeton
to be the conduit of funds,
I'll make the seed grant.
And I had met the Princeton
Development Director
because my thesis advisor
had insisted on it.
This man was gonna explain
to me how impossible
this was gonna be.
And I called that man.
And he was like, I cannot
believe you got a grant.
And he made it happen.
So anyway.
- And this I'm just hearing,
how much was the seed grant?
- $26,000, I mean, there's
- $26,000!
- I said, I'll come up with a budget.
These were my expenses for
the summer to fly all over.
- In today's money, that might be $40,000,
but not like an enormous amount of money,
but this was enough
money, was this, you know,
you was it like,
you could start taking a salary
to start flushing it out more.
You could start what other
other costs you might do
to do research.
- I don't even know if I had
a salary, but I had no money.
So I needed to live.
So it was like expenses
for a summer of like,
exploring whether this could work.
That that was how I
framed the whole thing.
- And how did you go from that?
And I do want to go into all
of the learning over the last,
especially well, recent times,
but especially over
the last three decades,
but how did you go from
that to a year later
having 500 people in a room
and having all of these,
it's one thing to get a $26,000 grant.
It's another thing to actually,
even though they were skeptical, I,
in hindsight it feels like
the student part have been the
easier part, but getting
the districts to say, yes,
we will place these teachers,
having enough money to do the training
for all of these folks,
being able to do it in a
responsible way so that you're
gonna put them in classrooms,
they're gonna be teaching
kids, et cetera, et cetera.
Like, was it a, just a
series of small steps?
- Yeah, I mean, it was all in
the four-page plan, but yes.
I will say, I mean, I think
every piece of this work is,
is a challenge, right?
Like I think actually one of
the hardest things we do still
to this day is inspire people
with a lot of other options
to say, I want to do this.
And so, but it is true that,
that there's a certain
group of people out there.
I think in that first year,
we magnetized the people who
saw this and were, you know,
I want to be part of that.
And I think as we work to
grow beyond that core group,
it became all the more
challenging to figure out
how to do it.
You know, the school district
part was not the hard part.
I still remember these
initial meetings I had
with urban district superintendents
and heads of human resources,
like one very memorable meeting
with the head of human resources
in the Los Angeles school district.
The guy started laughing.
He was looking at my list
of a hundred colleges
and he just laughed and said,
"I'll tell you what, you get students
"from these colleges to
want to teach in my schools.
"And I will hire all 500 of them."
And that was kind of the
reaction I was getting,
because there really there was just,
there was such a need for teachers.
And there was, in many ways,
it was a very different
world 30 years ago.
I mean, we've seen school
districts in the U S
become so much more sophisticated
in how they're recruiting teachers.
I mean, it used to be
a very different world.
Figuring out how to train them.
I found my way to really
progressive teacher educators.
And I knew, I knew we knew nothing.
So, I mean, we kind of
subcontracted with them and said,
please design a training
institute, you know?
And there was a lot, I mean,
you know, we were working 24/7,
there was a team of people, of course,
like a bunch of other recent graduates,
some who had taught some who
had done the Peace Corps,
others who were straight out of college
and were inspired by this mission.
But we put together an
amazing team of people,
young people who just made
it happen through a lot of
all-nighters and, you know, campaign.
- I think, I think young
people who are watching this,
I'm sure they are likely
impressed because it's not common
that you'll see a college senior
or someone who's 21 or 22 years old,
be able to do this level,
but we've had the last 20 or
30 years of seeing examples of,
especially in the for-profit
sector of startups being
founded by college students
and getting off the ground.
But when you started this,
this was not a normal thing.
It was not normal for someone
in their early twenties
to be able to start an,
an entity of substance.
But anyway, I know we're short of time,
but there must have been
something really powerful
about how you were presenting yourself,
or maybe you just had the right sponsors,
the right advocates or combination
that allowed you to get off the ground.
'Cause I would argue it's even harder
to start a not-for-profit of,
meaning relative to even a for-profit.
- I was obsessed with this idea.
And I think that was the thing, honestly,
more than anything else.
And it was an idea that
magnetized people immediately,
I mean, and it really
has a sense then, right.
And now it's doing that globally.
And there was a lot that that's
really what it came down to.
It was much less than, I
don't know that I would have,
I wasn't trying to think
of something to start.
I mean, that was like
the last thing I was not
in that mode at all.
It was just,
I became so obsessed with this
and I think that's what made it work.
- And now fast forward to today,
what are your big takeaways?
You had some hypotheses 30
years ago, or whenever it was,
which of those came true or
maybe are even better than what
you expected, which of
those the jury's still out.
And which of those are you like?
Well, I'm not sure if that was right,
but there's this other thing we learned.
- Mm.
So what's interesting about this, I mean,
as I shared earlier,
part of what I was so obsessed about
was the long-term impact I
thought this would have, like,
I thought it would really reshape
the priorities of a generation.
And I think I probably didn't understand
exactly how that piece
was going to play out,
but I think that piece has
happened in spades, you know,
and now there's all this research
and growing amounts of it
that look at what happens to these people
during the two years.
And we can look at it not only in the U S
but now in other countries as well.
And what's fascinating is that
these effects are so similar
even from country to country,
like people through those
two years, like they come in,
I mean,
they go through this very
rigorous selection process
and they come in, you know,
these studies look at people who are right
on the admissions line, some
didn't get in and some did.
And then it looks at what
happens to their mindsets
and beliefs and
understandings two years later
and beyond that.
And so they come in, you know,
the selection model works.
We select people who
believe in kids and families
and low-income communities,
but that conviction deepens like the gap
in their like level of belief
in the potential of kids
and families grows like, meaning,
like they believe more
in their kids at the end,
they also completely shift their
understanding of the nature
of the problem and the solutions.
Like they come in thinking
all around the world,
like the answer is technical, you know,
it's funding, number one and
number of technical solutions.
And they come out thinking
this is a big systemic problem
that's gonna take a lot of adaptive change
and a lot of leadership
from a lot of places.
So they basically come out
having a bigger sense of possibility,
knowing that no one silver
bullet is gonna do it.
Like this answer is much more complex
and they become all the
more committed to the work.
You know, they changed
their career trajectory.
They never leave the
work essentially, I mean,
you look at the 70,000,
some Teach for America,
alums and 86% of them are
full-time in the work.
Like some of them in education,
some of others taking on the
other aspects of the issues
in low income communities.
And we're seeing the same thing globally,
75% of these alumni all over
the world are still full-time
in education.
So that part, like the idea
that this was going to shape
these people and that it
would end up being not only
about two years, but about every year
after the two years like
that we got completely right.
I don't know if I could have known how
that would play itself out over time.
You know, I think, you
know, it's probably made
a bigger impact in the long
run and in my biased opinion
than I could have predicted
because of the nature of the
problem and the solution,
which we can talk about.
- And I only go in a second,
but how do you think it's affected
the education environment?
What's that alternative reality
where instead young Wendy Kopp went
and got a job as management consultant
and doesn't start Teach for America.
What would the world look like there?
- So this is where I was gonna go.
So I think what I've learned over time
and what all of these people
who get into this work learn,
and what I'm sure you've learned is
that this really is a
big, complex problem.
Like there is no one thing
that's gonna solve this problem,
like more great teachers,
a different curriculum,
a laptop for every kid,
a charter school, a different government.
I mean, there's no one thing.
It's gonna take so many different things.
Like it really is just
a very complex problem.
It's not even all about
schools and school systems.
It's about, you know, it's just,
it's about the fact that
a whole segments of kids
face many extra challenges
that more privileged kids
don't face, discrimination, poverty,
lack of access to adequate healthcare
and so many other things.
And then they show up
at schools never set up
to meet their extra needs.
And there's this kind
of prevailing ideology
about the potential of these
kind of marginalized kids.
And so to solve that is gonna
take collective leadership.
You know, it's gonna take a
lot of people working together.
It's gonna take teachers
and school leaders
and school system leaders.
It's gonna take the social entrepreneurs,
figuring out how to change the system.
It's gonna take policy leaders.
It's gonna take students
and parents and advocates.
You don't, we need a
whole ecosystem of people
exerting leadership.
And so I think what teach for
all network organizations have
done is contributed to
that collective leadership.
Like they're enlisting people, you know,
from very diverse backgrounds,
some who have lived these
inequities that we're addressing
and others from much more
privileged backgrounds.
So diverse group of folks,
they're immersing them in this experience.
And those people come out believing
we can solve this problem,
understanding the nature of the problem
and taking it on alongside
and in partnership
with many others, you
know, the systemic issues.
And so I think what's changed.
Like you can see now, I mean,
in the U S you can see communities
where Teach for America's
been placing a steady stream
of people for 30 years.
And I know it doesn't seem like it
because we still have massive inequities.
And we're far from where we want to be
as a country in education.
But if you actually looked at
where things were 30 years ago
in these communities
versus where they are now,
in terms of the state of education,
the educational outcomes,
we've moved the needle in a big way.
And not, of course, just
because of Teach for America.
But if you took all those
Teach for America people
out of those communities,
you would take a lot of
the energy and leadership
and entrepreneurship that
has fueled and catalyzed,
and in some cases really
driven the change.
And we're seeing just the same
effects all around the world.
It's almost like seeing
the same movie playing
in different countries.
- Yeah, and I'll add to that.
I'm sure it's had impact
on those communities,
but just even on my own
journey at Khan academy
over the last 11, 12, 13,
I guess it's been 16 years,
17 years since I started tutoring family.
But while I was doing this for real,
the number of Teach for America folks
that I've seen leading various orders,
we've had multiple Teach for
America folks at various stages
in Khan Academy all the
way to the early days
who did some of our
school partnership work,
the number of other
not-for-profits or for-profit,
but education, ed tech,
whatever you want to call it,
reform, your alumni are everywhere.
They are driving these things.
So I do think there's the direct impact
on those communities.
There's the ways that it has
changed these people directly
and their understanding of the system.
But it's also these, many of
your folks have gone out there
and then have become mini Wendy's
and have started other parts
as well, to your point,
it's a multidimensional approach.
There's many vectors here,
but going into the
teaching itself, you know.
There's a bunch of
questions that have coming
in from YouTube.
Raymond Cronin says, "How
do you get students on board
"with core classes they're
not interested in?"
There was another question.
"Can you describe the progress
"in education you've seen made?"
And so taking all that
into account, you know,
what have you found makes
someone a successful teacher?
And as to Raymond's question,
it's not just delivery of content.
It is motivation of content.
It's other things.
What's your takeaways here?
How do you see that talent
and how do you develop it?
- So, first of all, on
the teaching question,
and then let's come back
to that second question,
because that's a slightly different one,
but we've learned so much
and it's an ongoing learning journey.
I think, you know, my
biggest thought in listening
to that question and just
thinking about what we've learned
is that, you know, I guess I've rethought
what we're even working towards.
You know, when we started
out in this, I mean,
of course it's still, I mean,
we're so driven by equity
across the teach for all network
and working with the
most marginalized kids.
I think when I started my
Teach for America journey,
I was thinking that meant catching kids up
to where more privileged kids are.
And progressively,
we just realized how insufficient that is.
Like we're catching kids
up in a very broken system.
When what we should be
doing is enabling kids
and developing them to
exert the leadership,
to solve the inequities,
to shape a better future for themselves,
like navigate a changing economy.
And for all of us like solve
these pressing problems
that face our society.
So it's interesting,
like we did a whole set
of studies back in the day
about what differentiated teachers
who produced the biggest
gains in student achievement,
you know, standardized test scores,
but we've redone all those
studies now looking at what is it
that differentiates the teachers
who are fostering students'
agency, their awareness in the world,
their problem solving
skills, their leadership,
you know, including their, you know,
ability to apply the academic
knowledge, to be strong,
critical thinkers and strong
problem solvers and all.
And so I guess what's come out
of those studies is the idea
that the strongest teachers, first of all,
are so purpose driven.
Like they are very clear
on their ultimate aim.
They build really strong
relationships with their students
and the students' families,
and other teachers in the school.
And then they're just,
they're making choices
that foster student agency
and awareness and wellbeing and mastery.
I'm gonna pause.
I mean, there are so many,
there's so much to be
said on this topic, but.
- And what's your sense about, you know,
when you're looking at
these young people going
into the Teach for America
or the Teach for All force,
is there any way to find
that signal early on,
or do they just have to learn as they go,
and then how do people change
with time and experience?
'Cause I've definitely heard
the argument both ways.
These are incredibly high potential folks,
but then you might have senior teachers
who might not have quite
the same background,
but they've learned things over the years.
How do you see that develop over time?
- Yeah.
I mean,
every teacher's journey is of
course a little bit different.
And one thing I would just say, I mean,
we are trying to, on the teaching side,
be one more source of, you
know, deeply committed teachers,
working alongside many other
teachers and allies and parents
and others trying to help kids, you know,
meet their extra needs, you know,
support them to live into
their full potential.
And it's a journey.
It's a learning journey
for any new teacher,
including those who we place in support.
I'm losing track of your
question, but, yeah.
- How you think it evolves over time?
Like what, how do you see the,
even the, in the two years,
how do you see your teachers change
between year one and year two?
What are they doing differently?
- Yeah, you know,
it's so interesting because I just talked
to a first-year teacher
in Columbia who is working
with a hundred students
across grades five through 10,
and he's teaching math and physics,
and he's never met the kids
because he's only taught in the pandemic.
And he's somehow started
by teaching the kids
about the UN sustainable
development goals.
And then he got them all involved
in researching the reality
in rural Colombia.
And then they became very
concerned about the water shortage
and the gas shortage.
And these kids have developed
solutions to those problems.
And he's literally hooked them
up with professors who are
like, please walk me through
the 3D thing that you've like.
So he's a first year teacher
and he immediately just
oriented towards how do we
foster students' leadership?
Like, let's do it today.
'Cause there are lots of
problems in the world today.
And he, I mean, he said a fifth grade girl
is leading the team.
He then entered them into
these different competitions
and they've done very well.
And he has a fifth grade
girl leading a team.
I mean, so it's hard, you know,
and then there were other
first year teachers who come in
through our organization who, you know,
are completely overwhelmed
and who, if they persist,
you know, by the end of the year,
wake up and realize they
did make a difference
and then reflect over
the summer and come in,
hitting the ground
running the second year.
I mean, I don't want to
say there's one journey,
but yeah, it's, I mean,
we're selecting a group of people who one,
want to be in this work,
who are deeply driven
to address these inequities
who want to be in the arena.
One, you know, have high
expectations for kids and families.
And we're looking for various things,
but including a lot of evidence
that they take on big things
and persevere in the face of challenges,
because that's a huge part of this.
We're looking for people who
also build strong relationships
that can influence and motivate others.
And I think that's another,
just really fundamental piece.
I mean, all of our studies
about transformational teachers,
it's interesting.
Like the number one
differentiator is that they're
incredibly relational,
not even just the kids,
but with anyone like the
other teachers in the building
and such.
So, you know, there's a lot to like trying
to select those folks
and invest putting them
in a culture and helping them understand
and see like different models
of teachers who are fostering
their students' leadership
and building their skills
and providing the ongoing
coaching and mentoring
and access to resources
necessary to develop over time.
- Yeah, makes a ton of sense.
And I just realized whenever
I'm having a good conversation,
the time goes far faster than I expect.
So maybe we finish off this,
a question from CL Grouse on
Facebook, "Being that we have
"been a pandemic for almost two years,
"are there any changes
within the organization
"that weren't there prior to 2020?"
So if you could take us home
on what does a pandemic done
to Teach for All to teaching
and any other takeaways
you want folks to have?
- Yeah.
You know,
I think this in a way,
Teach for All's network
was kind of made for this era.
I think it's just been really affirming
for the kind of teachers and
leaders we're developing,
who as the world's schools shut down
progressively just leaned
in with their own students
to keep them safe and learning.
And then we're very quickly enlisted
by government ministries around the world
and others to train other teachers
in distance learning strategies,
create digital libraries,
leverage radio and TV
to keep kids learning.
And so we've just seen so much leadership
and so much innovation across our network.
And we've also seen the power
of having a global network
that would enable all those
teachers and alumni educators
to learn from each other.
I mean, we just saw solutions
flying across the world.
So that's maybe a part of the answer.
We've been reflecting a lot
on what we're learning in this era.
And of course we're seeing
the issues we're addressing,
with the inequities we're addressing,
just hugely exacerbated in this time,
but we're also seeing a
lot of new possibilities,
like mindset shifts.
A lot of them among the world's educators.
I mean our networks educators
and the world's educators
about the power of leveraging technology,
the power of engaging students
in shaping the learning experience,
like partnering with them to do that.
The power of partnering
all the more deeply
with parents,
the importance of integrating a focus
on wellbeing and social,
emotional development
at every single step of
the way and every day
and probably more.
But, so we're really thinking about
how do we sustain those mindsets?
Because if we can do that,
we really have the potential
to have a different and
much better school system
as we go forward.
- No, it's so exciting.
And Wendy, I would say I
could talk to you for hours.
And I will say I, you've
always been an inspiration,
the existence.
I didn't know you when
I started Khan Academy,
we got to know each other quite quickly.
I consider myself very fortunate, but I,
the existence of Teach for
America and Teach for All
is what gave me confidence
that you could have innovative
not-for-profits at scale
that can really make a dent
at a national or global level.
And obviously what we're trying to do
and are the various not-for-profits.
We also have a habit of
starting more than one
not-for-profit, then the
various not-for-profits
that we're doing, obviously,
I've started a tutoring platform,
schoolhouse.world.
In some ways, it rhymes with a lot of what
you're talking about, about
people wanting to give back.
And I think what we're
doing is so complimentary,
I'm super excited about
where education can go
with your entrepreneurship
and these 70,000 folks
that you have joined your army.
Thank you for doing that for the world.
- Well, thank you, Sal and
your journey has also been
a huge source of inspiration and support
to our whole network and so many leaders
across our network and I myself.
So thank you for that.
We really value our kind
of informal partnership
with Khan Academy.
- Absolutely.
Well, thank you so much.
Well, thanks everyone for joining.
- [Wendy] Thank you so much.
- Thanks so much, Wendy.
Thanks everyone for joining.
As you can tell, Wendy is one of the real,
if you think of a list of five
people in the last 30 years
who you would list on making
a dent in the universe,
especially a dent in the
universe and education,
I think Wendy would make that list.
So thank you for joining
and as you could see,
she's incredibly inspiring
and her journey is incredibly inspiring.
So thank you for joining the homeroom.
And I will see all at the next one,
which is still gonna be in a little while,
but we'll see you all there.
(chimes flutter)